Okay.
Um
Welcome to the DDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk, and please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end.
Uh second, today's DDPS seminar is open
to external audiences. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed.
Finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Um
uh let me introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr. uh Khalid
Jawwed, uh who is an associate professor
in the Department of Mechanical and
Aerospace Engineering of the University
of California, Los Angeles.
And the principal investigator of the
structure
computer uh interaction laboratory. He
received his PhD and master's degree in
mechanical engineering engineering from
um MIT in 2016 and 2014.
Uh he holds dual bachelor's degree in
aero- uh space engineering and engineer-
um
engineering physics from the University
of Michigan, Ann Arbor. Uh he also
served as a postdoctoral researcher at
Carnegie Mellon University. He received
an NSF Career Award in 2021,
the outstand- outstanding teaching award
from UCLA in 2019, the outstanding
teaching assistant award from MIT in
2015, and the and then um the GSNP best
speaker award at the American Physical
Society March Meeting in 2014. Today,
Khalid will present an exciting topic,
which is reduced order modeling and
inverse design of
flexible structures by machine learning.
Please enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk. Now, without further ado, let me
pass the baton to Khalid
uh by asking one random question as
usual. Uh, I it's it's easy question.
Uh, what is your favorite movie, Khalid?
I think my favorite movie is, uh, The
Good, the Bad, and the Ugly. Uh, it's a
western movie here by Clint Eastwood.
Uh, and I usually like most of Clint
Eastwood movies.
Oh, I see. Okay. Well, stage is yours.
Okay.
Thank you. Well, uh, thank you, Dr.
Choi, for introducing me. Uh,
my name is Khalid Jawed. I'm an
assistant professor at UCLA.
Uh, today I'll be talking about reduced
order modeling and inverse design. So,
I'll be talking about forward
simulations and backward design.
And we'll be using a combination of
physics, of course, and machine
learning. And, uh,
the content of my talk is based on work
done by my students and postdocs. They
are Dizhong Tong, Andrew Choi, uh,
Lexian Ma, who is now an assistant
professor at Arizona State, Shaofeng Li,
who is now a postdoc at MIT, uh, Tiani
Wang, uh, who joined the industry last
year, and Run My Mungikar and Shubham
Panda. Both of them are PhD students in
my lab. Uh, this work was done in
collaboration with Professor Jun Sok Joo
and Tony Roy Choudhury of UCLA, as well
as Professor Miha Brojan of the
University of Ljubljana in Slovenia.
Uh, broadly speaking, the work in my lab
is in the intersection of mechanics,
which is, uh, my PhD field.
Our primary focus, uh, application area
is robotics. So, we use mechan-
mechanics-based tools and simulations in
robotics.
As well as we also use machine learning
and computer graphics. These are some of
the main tools in our toolbox.
So,
uh,
let me give you a brief outline of my
talk today.
Uh, first I'll be talking about
physics-based simulations of
of, uh, of rods, right? So, ropes and
tying knots in ropes. I won't talk about
machine learning in the first part.
Then, I will talk about using machine
learning for model reduction, right? So,
how can I speed up these physics-based
simulations? For example, how can I uh
reduce a complicated rod model into a
simplified beam model? And then, I will
talk about how I can reduce a plate
model to a
simpler rod model. The last part of my
talk, I will talk about inverse design.
So, given a target shape, how can I go
about achieving that shape?
So,
before we go in go into the into the
crux of my talk, let's go over some
definitions. Yeah, I My understanding is
uh not all of you are familiar with
mechanics.
So, there are various
terms like beams, rods, ribbons, plates,
and shells. Like, what are those? So, a
beam is a structure whose length is much
much larger than the height and the
width. And a beam can only bend, so it
will undergo two-dimensional
deformation.
A rod
is geometrical similar to a beam. It has
Its length is much much larger than the
uh width and the height. For example, a
plant's tendril,
it can bend, but also it can twist. And
depending on some rod model, it can
stretch as well. So, the deformation can
happen in 3D. For example, in this
plant's tendril.
A ribbon is close to a rod, but its
length is much much larger than the
width and its width is much much larger
than the height. So, this is an example
of a ribbon.
Um
plates and shells. Uh so, a plate, its
length and width are of a similar order
of magnitude, but both of these two
dimensions are much much larger than the
height.
The natural configuration of a plate is
two-dimensional. So, initially it is
two-dimensional, but then under
deformation, it can take
three-dimensional shape.
A shell is a super set of plates.
So, a the natural configuration of a of
a shell can be three-dimensional. For
example, this hat here.
So, the
in first part of my talk, I will talk
about simulation of rods.
And uh specially when it comes to things
like contact and friction, for example,
when you're tying your shoelace or tying
some simple knot,
uh contact and friction can be
important. And how can we
purely using physics, how can we go
about developing fast simulation of
such uh such structures?
Uh similar simulation method can be used
for
cables and ropes and and surgery uh
and and so on.
So, before we go into discrete elastic
rods algorithm, let's think of a simple
mass-spring system, okay?
It has two degrees of freedom, X1 and
X2. I can write down
just using Newton's second law, I can
write down equations of motion, which is
mass times acceleration is equal to the
sum of elastic or internal and external
force.
The elastic force,
that is just Hooke's law tells me it's
just K time -K times X, right?
I can write it like this. The elastic
force is the negative gradient of the
elastic energy, and the elastic energy
spring is 1/2 KX squared, right? Nothing
to
interesting about this.
We will be using a similar method to
to simulate uh
rods as well as knots tied in rod tied
in rods.
So, the the model behind the rod
simulation that goes back to Kirchhoff,
and we'll be using some variation of uh
Kirchhoff rod model. The elastic energy
for a spring is 1/2 k kx squared. For a
rod, it is the sum of three types of
energies: elastic bending, elastic
twisting, and elastic stretching, right?
So, bending means you Of course, you
know what is bending. Twisting means you
hold the rod and then you you rotate one
end with respect to the other. And
stretching means you just try to
elongate the rod or you try to compress
the rod.
Now, we'll be using a simulation tool
we'll be we'll be adopting a simulation
tool called the discrete elastic rods.
So, this simulation tool will develop
was developed by the computer graphics
community uh and it has been used in
movies like The Lord of the Rings and
Planet of the Apes and The Hobbit for
simulation of of hair and fur and other
rod-like structures.
And uh we imported this simulation tool
to mechanical engineering. This was done
during my PhD and we studied things like
uh
coiling of rods, bacterial locomotion,
carbon nanotubes, and so on using
a similar simulation tool.
Now, in DER or discrete elastic rods,
the continuous rod
is represented by the center line gamma
as well as
the twist angle theta. So, when I want
to fully describe a rod, I don't need I
I in addition to the center line, I also
need the rotation of the material frame
of the rod along the center line, right?
That is why in addition to the center
line gamma, I need this rotation
information or twist information theta.
So, before we implement this in our
numerical algorithm, we divide the rod
into a bunch of nodes.
And my degrees of freedoms
are the nodal coordinates xi
as well as the rotation angle or twist
angle theta i,
right?
Then, my total elastic force of this rod
is the sum of stretching, bending, and
twisting energies across all the nodes.
Okay?
Then, what I will be doing is I can
simply use this type of equation to
solve
for the configuration of the rod. Right?
So, then I can I can simulate I can move
forward in in time.
Now,
I would like to point out that this is
different than let's say finite element
method.
The reason is I am building up the
energy in the discrete setting.
And then, so I have the energy
formulation in discrete setting.
And then, I will be
using uh Newton's second law at every
degree of freedom
to simulate the new to simulate this uh
this structural system. Right? This is
different than finite element because in
a finite element, you have um
you're solving the smooth equations
assuming some discretization.
Okay?
So, now let's write down our
uh equations of motion for discrete
elastic rods. So, this is a system of
equations.
So, if I have n nodes, I will have three
n degrees of freedom for the nodal
coordinates.
And n minus one degrees of freedom for
this theta angle. So, in total, I have
4n minus one equations of motion.
Right?
I will be writing down the elastic
energies.
So, the bending energy is related to
the change in angle between
two subsequent edges. Right? An edge is
the cylinder connecting two nodes.
Right? So, this like this angle is kind
of the turning angle. And I can
formulate by bend my bending energy from
this turning angle.
The twisting energy, again, I'm not
going into the details of the
mathematics here um because this was
done like in 2010. So, I just want to of
glance over it. Twisting energy is
related to the change in the theta
angle.
Stretching stretching energy is related
to how much I'm pulling What is the
elongation in the
in each cylinder
in between two nodes.
So then I can write down elastic energy
like this, right? So my elastic energy
is a sum of these small packets of
energies at every node.
These small packets of discrete energies
at every node that depend on the two
curvatures that coming from bending
the twist that is coming from twisting
the axial stretch which is coming from
stretching and
a set of parameters that I call theta.
All right.
I can take the gradient of the elastic
energies like this and get my expression
for the elastic force, right? So this is
where I will be plugging in this
expression.
This theta parameter, the reason I'm
using this is to draw some parallel
between neural networks. This theta
parameter is essentially the
constitutive law, right? So for a rod,
if I'm using a purely physics-based
model, they will be related to terms
like bending stiffness EI, twisting
stiffness GJ,
uh stretching stiffness EA where E is
the is the Young's modulus.
Anyway, so I can
divide my second-order differential uh
equation that represent that represent
the the equations of motion, I can
divide it into two first-order
uh differential equation and then I can
I can solve it, right?
Um
I forgot to mention that the external
energy that is problem-specific, right?
Sometimes I will have friction,
sometimes I will have gravity, sometimes
I'll have a combination of the of the of
the
of a few external energies.
So, we have used this method and
implemented contact and friction
to simulate, let's say things like a
soft robot.
So, I have experiments on top and
simulations at the bottom. The
experiments were done at Carnegie Mellon
with Carmel Majidi's group, and the
simulations were done at UCLA.
Uh this robot is a shape memory
polymer sorry, shape memory alloy based
robot. So, there shape memory alloys
embedded inside these soft composites,
and by actuating, that is applying
current to the shape memory alloy, I can
selectively
actuate one or more limbs.
So, now this is an example where I have
inclined the plane by 3°. So, instead of
perpendicular to gravity, the
plane is 3° with
uh the normal to the plane is
makes an angle of 3° with gravity.
But then if I make it 6°,
uh in both experiments and simulations,
the robot cannot move forward. So, this
is important because now I can see that
my simulation is fast, but also it can
actually
uh has predictive ability.
This is an example on a sign on a
sinusoidal surface, and then if I start
the robot from the top of the sign uh
sign curve,
you'll see that they both of them will
roll.
Um
and of course there are there are some
differences between experiments and
simulations um
that has to do with a number of fitting
parameters and and and so on, but
still they're qualitatively accurate.
So, now if I
plot the computational time divided by
wall clock time as a function of the
time step size of the simulations for a
few cases,
uh
if I take a
like a time step size below 10 to the
power of minus 3 second, my simulation
will still
above 10 to the power of minus 3
seconds. So, if I take like a larger
time step,
my simulation still converges, but I can
actually run this thing faster than than
real time using a preliminary
implementation. However, in the future
we can we can think that you know, like
we can speed up we can further speed up
the
computation
and use it for uh for real-time control.
So, this is um
uh
the this robot that I showed that is
still
um
you know, like as a everything was
happening in 2D, right?
So, what I want to do now is that I want
to show that we can actually run
simulations with a bit more complicated
three-dimensional topology. And this
work was done uh at UCLA with Andrew
Choi and Zongtong. Both of them are my
PhD students.
A really critical part of
external
force is uh
is the forces that will come from
friction and contact.
Now, the main contribution of this work
was to augment DER to properly account
things like friction and contact. And
the way we do it is we treat the contact
almost like an internal or elastic
energy, okay? So, let's say I'm zooming
in into I'm zooming into
a so-called contact pair.
So, I have a rod.
Some and the rod is composed of a number
of cylinders.
There pairs of cylinders that will
contact each other, okay? So, let's say
this is one cylinder and this is another
cylinder.
The minimum distance between them is
delta, okay?
Now, for simplicity, let's take a
two-dimensional view.
If they contact each other and if
there's relative motion between the two,
which is Vrel,
I will have a frictional force and a
contact force. Contact force will try to
prevent contact and frictional force
will try to prevent the relative motion.
Now,
theoretically, if I want to come up with
a term like contact energy
as a function of the H2S distance delta,
right? Which is the minimum distance
between
two cylinders.
Then, theoretically, it is a Heaviside
step function. Like that
if the minimum distance between
two cylinders, if that is larger than
the diameter of the rod, then there is
no contact energy. If it is below that,
then the contact energy is infinity.
Uh because
it the contact is is
is not possible, at least theoretically.
However, what we do is
if I smooth on this energy
so that I can take derivatives of it.
We do see a lot of without any without
much sacrifice in physical accuracy, we
will see comp- operational
speed up. Because now, instead of
dealing with constraints,
I can take the gradient and Hessian of
this contact energy and implement that
in my DR simulation.
So,
I'm not going over the details of all
the implementation, but let's do a test
with the simulation. Let's do a test
with simple overhand knot.
Depending on the number of turns in the
knot, which I call unknotting number N,
let's say I tie a knot
one, two, three, or four turns in my
overhand knot.
And I I keep pulling on it, you will see
that there will be a
buckling. It's called snap buckling.
And this the onset of buckling will
depend on the unknotting number. So,
when N equals to four,
the buckling happened the
the soonest, then buckling happened here
when N equals to three. Eventually,
buckling will happen at n equals to two.
At n equals to one, it will never
undergo buckling. So, we have done
qualitative as well as have as sub
quantitative studies to show that our
method actually works. However, I'm kind
of skipping
those validations, but at least we can
actually run these examples.
Here's another example which has a bit
more of a practical significance.
And this has to do with simulation of
bacteria.
What happens in bacteria is there will
be often times there will be two or more
so-called flagella or helical
structures. They will be rotating next
to one another.
And
because of hydrodynamic attraction
between multiple flagella, they'll come
close and form a bundle. And this
mechanism is used by various common
bacteria like salmonella and E. coli and
so on.
This is a model experiment from 2003
by Tom Powers at Brown University and
his collaborators.
What we have done here is we have
incorporated
our contact model
with hydrodynamics. I didn't go over the
details of hydrodynamic implementation,
but I'm just showing you that it is
possible.
And then depending on how many filaments
I have, of course the shape and the
bundling behavior and all of that that
will be
very different.
So, here I assume that the friction is
zero.
Just purely because of hydrodynamic
attraction, so multiple parts of the
filament
are generating flows. Those flows are
interacting with one another and that is
causing the filaments to actually come
together and form a bundle, which is
something that is known to happen in in
bacteria.
Now,
in the later part of the video
you I uh I Here what you see is I'm
changing the friction coefficient. Uh
just to show that if I increase the
friction coefficient, the bundling
behavior will be slightly different, and
we can qualitatively capture uh this
behavior. So when friction coefficient
is zero,
there is contact
uh and
and initially all of them kind of look
similar, but as time goes on,
you'll see that there's more contact
here, and less contact here. So this can
give us some insight about, you know,
about the surface property or this of
bacterial flagella. Or this can at least
help us design bacteria-inspired robots.
That is something that we're doing in
our lab as well.
Okay. And then we of course we we have
to do comparison with the state of the
art. Uh so there is another method
called uh implicit incremental potential
contact uh that also came out but
recently in 2020, and we do some
comparison. This I would say is kind of
the uh column to look at. Uh our run
time is from some simple from
preliminary studies it looks like looks
like that our run time is better than um
the the method from uh 2020.
All right. So this is why I didn't use
any machine learning, but I showed what
I showed is that we have some
physics-based numerical methods that are
pretty fast, can simulate contact
friction, and we have shown that we can
apply them to study robots and uh
bacterial flagella and so on, right?
So now
um I want to
take I want to keep the crux of this
physics-based algorithm, but I want to
augment it using using machine learning.
And what I want to show is that we can
use machine learning to reduce a
three-dimensional rod model into a
simplified beam model. So, I want to cut
down
the degrees of freedom so that the
computation is faster.
And I want to you kind of learn from
experimental and or fine-grained
simulation data the constitutive
behavior of the system, right?
I'm taking Slinky as an example. Uh it's
just there's a test case. So, Slinky is
pretty cool because you know, like
people kids use it. It can walk down the
stairs like in this video.
And uh other researchers have tried to
develop uh reduced models for Slinky.
So, for example,
in this study,
uh the Slinky was represented as its
center line, right? Now, most of the
time the simulation the the deformation
of a Slinky is restricted to 2D. So, I
can actually just use two-dimensional
beam model.
In theory, I should in principle I
should be able to use some variation of
two-dimensional beam model to simulate
Slinky. However,
the elastic bending energy, right? That
is no longer
uh
bending stiffness times curvature
squared or anything, right? It is going
to be a lot more complicated. So, for
example, in this study, they tried to
come up with a elastic energy model like
this.
Uh and there's some similar
applications. Uh for example, a soft
robot can be
simulated as its spine using its
spine-based model. And a unit actuator,
I can also try to simulate that using
its beam-based center line, right?
Now,
before I go into
Now, I will show how we can use machine
learning to to uh reduce the model from
a three-dimensional rod to a 2D beam.
But before that, I just want to kind of
uh qualitatively explain what will be
what is it that will be going on. When
we are when you
you're developing an end-to-end machine
learning model of
a time varying system, often times
we
model both the underlying governing
equations
as well as the constitutive behavior.
However,
we know that the underlying governing
equations
that are sometimes well known. That is
just often that is just F equals to MA
like equation.
What we should focus on is
enforce the governing equations
but try to learn the constitutive law.
For training a framework like this, we
can either use experiments or we can use
like a purely physics-based but
fine-grained computationally expensive
simulation, right?
Right now, we're focusing more on using
existing purely physics-based
simulations that are pretty time
consuming. However, in the future we can
envision that experimental data can be
used to train this model, which will be
pretty cool because then we can imagine
that, you know, a robot will
learn from its behavior and then come up
with
reduced models that can run real fast in
its brain in its
in in its CPU and adapt
its its locomotion.
So, I can use Now, in my case, I can use
a three-dimensional DER to model this
model something like this.
Or I can use just the this red center
line to simulate the same thing.
And how to learn the constitutive law of
this red center line so that I can
simulate it faster is the goal.
This is where we'll be using a method
from 2018 called called neural ordinary
differential equations.
So, you know, a ResNet is a a series of
layers like this. So, Xt + 1 is Xt +
some
in combination of parameters.
Neural ODE
is a framework to learn a system in the
continuous
in its continuous limit. So, I can learn
a system like I can learn theta where
theta is my constitutive parameters, if
you recall from my from the first part
of my talk, right?
Now, in our work we cast our system
like this. So, again, if you recall from
from the first part of my talk that I
said that I can
divide my second order differential
equation into two first-order equations.
And what I have to learn now is I have
to learn what are these theta
parameters. For a three-dimensional DER,
the theta parameters are related to
bending stiffness, twisting stiffness,
and stretching stiffness and so on. But
now,
I am representing a three-dimensional
Slinky using a beam, right? Now, the
theta parameters or the constitutive
parameters for that beam is not known,
right? That is something that we have to
learn.
So, let's go over the method to do that,
So, I I decompose a Slinky into uh
NC minus two two for the two end
terminals, right? So, NC minus two
triplets.
So, I take three three rings, right?
And decompose my Slinky into that. Now,
at every ring, right? I have three nodes
and a uh and and this alpha parameter,
which is the angle that the mid node
will make with the gravity.
Now, I'll be using a relative coordinate
system so that my results don't depend
on um
on my choice of the coordinate frame.
So, I can use zeta one, zeta two, zeta
three, and zeta four. These four
parameters to
as my
uh degrees of freedom. Okay?
And then, of course, if I know these
parameters, I can back calculate
uh
the nodal nodal coordinates, as well as
this alpha angle.
I'll be using my same equations of
motion, right? So, mass times
acceleration is equal to the elastic
force, plus
my external force now is some damping
plus gravity. And the elastic force is
just the negative gradient of the
elastic energy. Okay?
And the elastic energy is the sum of all
the elastic energies, and each elastic
energy is located at the triplet.
One thing to keep in mind is and this is
something really critical and one of the
contributions of our work is that, okay,
uh
I need to account for not just
translational and rotational symmetry, I
also need to make sure that reflection
along X, Y, or compound reflections,
reflection along both X and Y,
they don't affect my formulation, right?
My translation and rotation, that is
taken care of because I'm using relative
coordinate system.
To make sure that reflection
reflections don't matter, what I do is I
feed my result
I Sorry, I feed my
degrees of freedom parameters, the Zeta
parameters,
and a copy of it through X reflection, a
copy of it through Y reflection, and a
copy of it through compound reflection,
feed it through the neural network, and
add all of them up. And then, of course,
I can divide it by four if I if I want
to.
So, that I guarantee that my energy
doesn't depend on reflection. And of
course, it doesn't depend on translation
and rotation. And this is the neural
network
architecture that was used.
And I'm going to be using again this
uh equations of motion.
And I have a formulation now for my
uh elastic energy
and my elastic force
and I train these data parameters within
my constitutive law or represents my
constitutive law using full
three-dimensional discrete elastic rods
framework.
Right?
And um
now I have trained my elastic energy
and then I will be you and I I'll be
using a scale I'll be using a flowchart
like this like a method like this. So
I won't go over it again. I don't want
to go over the details of this you have
to very briefly kind of explain what is
going on. So I divide a slinky into a
bunch of triplets. I feed the each
triplet through my neural network. Then
I get the elastic energy.
I know how to calculate my gravity and
my damping parameters. I add all of them
up and say that is equal to mass times
acceleration and then I solve my
uh,
my equations of motion, right? So in my
experiments, my DR simulation and my
reduced order machine learning assisted
simulation
uh, and you know, of course they seem to
agree with each other.
Now if I do my uh, comparison with times
like competition time comparison
in this case uh, DR is or like ML
assisted simulation is about uh, 50
times 50 to 60 times faster than than
full order DR simulation, right? So this
is just to show that the potential the
potential that um, you know, we can
we already have a fast simulation tool
that can that has been used in movies
and so on, but depending on the setup we
can even speed up this uh, this
simulations and then use them for things
like control and optimization and so on.
Right?
So this is my um, in this video like
we're first tra- using some data to
train
we're training and then we're
extrapolating uh, a long time.
But now I think the better so the better
part of this algorithm is that I can
change the size of the slinky and I
don't have to use any more retraining.
But and my DR experiments on neural
network, they kind of all seem to agree.
I can even change the boundary condition
and I have experiments DR and neural
network. So of course now the neural
network based simulation that kind of
starts to deviate a little bit, but that
has to do with with training accuracy.
If I half my density,
even then it can work. If I half my
elasticity, then the bountiness will be
even more. So
then my DR and neural network both based
simulation, both of them seem to agree.
Then we should of course compare with
some
I would I would call them brute force
methods.
So like you know you can use a
confidence convolutional neural network
to essentially map right one
one triplet to the next triplet. And we
are using the same neural network for
ESNN which is our proposed method and
convolutional
neural network. Actually we're not using
a similar network. This is using a CNN.
Um
But anyways using
if pure CNN is used then it starts to
deviate after some time. So we train it
on here, but then it don't generalize to
to
changes in boundary condition.
I can directly I can use
I can directly
compare that with
force based method. So I I map my
coordinates to forces. Now here I use
the same neural like a similar neural
network architecture, not the same, but
the architecture remains the same. So
the number of layers and nodes they
remain the same.
Like it fails after some time. I can
also use purely energy based methods. So
I'm just
you know like I'm
just mapping one coordinate to the the
system of coordinates to energy.
And it still doesn't work very well.
One of the reasons is that
that when you train your neural network,
right, there will always be some error.
And when you want to use that neural
network in a
in a in a method like Newton's method,
you'll need a gradient and the Hessian.
So, those little errors in a neural
network, you take the gradient of it and
Hessian of it, that seem to blow up.
Now,
another question is can physicists
sometimes use these methods, right?
For example, can we get physical insight
from my from my neural net from the
trained neural network?
So, I'm plotting the energy from the
trained neural network as a function of
this
I would call it the bending angle.
I'm plotting the energy as a function of
this bend angle at different values of
of length, or rather the distance
between triplets.
Imagine that if you elongate a triplet,
it gets stiffer. So, it is the more
difficult to bend.
If you elongate a springy, it gets more
difficult to bend. So, this is what we
what we see that the the higher the
length, the more
difficult it gets to bend.
Okay. This far, what we have done is um
we have
looked at
how we can reduce a 3D rod model into a
2D beam model. How can I learn the
constitutive law?
Now, what I want to do is I want to take
another example to go one step forward.
So, now I want to show that okay, how
can I take a plate model which is more
difficult than or more computationally
expensive than a rod model and then cast
that to a rod model.
Um I'll be using the example of a ribbon
and I'm going to discuss the problem
problem formulation in a minute. So, a
ribbon again,
its
length is much much larger than the
width and the height.
A rod, its length is much much larger
than the width, and the The is usually
on the same order of magnitude as
height. A plate, on the other hand, is
length and width, both of them are much
much larger than height.
Now,
um
a ribbon is a subset of plate.
I can use a plate simulation to simulate
a rib- ribbon. However, a ribbon is not
a subset of rod. So, I cannot take a rod
simulation and expect that a ribbon
simulation will
and and ribbon will be captured by the
same simulation. I'll show examples in a
minute.
Now, for this framework, for this
overall project, where I want to cast I
want to use a rod model to simulate a
ribbon model.
I know that I cannot use simple
physics-based rod model,
but can I use machine learning to
augment it?
Before that, um let's just briefly talk
about how we simulate plates. It's kind
of like a similar, so I divide a plate
into a bunch of triangles, and the angle
between the normals of two subsequent
two near between two nearby triangles
will give rise to bending energy. Okay,
this is the given by this equation here.
Again, let's not discu- let's not get
bogged down in equations.
And then, in between every two nodes,
for example, let's say xi and xj, there
is some stretching energy. If I want to
move one node far from the other, then
that will give rise to
stretching energy.
So,
in this study, we will be only
considering
we'll be only using plate simulation,
not shells.
And keep again, keep in mind that
ribbons are subset of shells, or subset
of plates.
And so, of course, a plate simulation
will be able to capture a ribbon
like the deformation of a ribbon.
Now, let's see some pictures, and let's
talk about our setup.
Uh
let's say I have a ribbon in between two
clamps.
I first
compress the ribbon, so that it takes a
bent shape like this and then I apply
transverse or shear displacement. So, I
move one clamp relative to the other
clamp.
So,
we will be in our study
we will be looking at this deformation
and then we will try to see if we can
capture it using
uh
using rod rod-based algorithms. So, here
I'm just using plate simulation.
I'm showing four videos at four
different values of width, okay?
The wide ribbon that undergoes
this
so-called super critical pitchfork
bifurcation the
the
soonest,
and as the width decreases, the onset of
bifurcation happens later.
I'll show options in a minute.
So, here in the first column I have some
small deformation and we call it the U
shape. And then
it will take so-called US shape,
which is when bifurcation happens and
then it will take
so-called S shape, all right?
And in its
when it is going over when it is going
through this bifurcation as well as
after the bifurcation, I can have US
plus and US
US plus and US minus as well as S plus
and S minus shape. So, there are like
two possibilities.
To show like to understand why the why
we study this thing, this is actually
pretty important important mechanics
problem.
So, if I plot let's say the height of
the midpoint as a function of normalized
shear or how much displacement I have
applied, right?
I see a
curve like this. So, initially the
height is a lot and then as I'm moving
one clamp away from the other, the
height starts to decrease.
If I plot the reaction force, this is
this red line,
it reaches a maximum here,
which indicates supercritical pitchfork
bifurcation.
Now, if I plot
Let's say plot the height as a function
of the shear angle,
I see plots like this. Okay?
This is the same plot like this. All
right? So,
plot like this. I I'm again plotting the
height as a function of shear angle. For
a
narrow ribbon, so the height over length
ratio is 1 over 20.
So, its width is 1 over 20th the length.
But, if I keep increasing the width,
what do we see?
I am plotting my results from rod model,
plate model, and experiments.
The plate model and the experiments,
right? They always agree.
So, experiments are in circles, plate
model is this green line.
The rod model, initially it agrees,
and then as the ribbon gets wider, it
doesn't agree.
This kind of makes sense because when a
ribbon is really thin, it is kind of
like a rod. And when the ribbon is
wider, it is act behaves more and more
like a plate.
But, one developing one-dimensional
ribbon model is a problem that goes back
to 1930s. And people have been trying to
come up with a lot of these equations to
instead of using 1/2 EI kappa squared
plus 1/2 GJ tau squared plus 1/2 EA
stretching squared, which is my usual
expression for Kirchhoff rod model,
they've been trying to come up with
these equations that are uh
You know, they're they're like
they're really interesting and very
impressive. However, why don't we just
simply use a neural network? Right? Um
given the advances in in in neural
network that we have.
This is This is what we'll be doing.
Instead of using an equation like this,
I will be expressing the energy model as
a neural network. So, I'll be summing up
the energy at every node. They will
depend on the curvatures, the twist, and
the stretching. And now I have to
calculate the valid these weights and
prime weights and biases theta.
So, I'll be using same the neural ODE
framework, and I'll be kind of going
through the same process more or less.
Um
Uh when it comes to training, it looks
like things get a little bit more
complicated. So, it kind of like you
have to train it you have to choose the
right training data,
uh right part of the training data, and
you know, and you kind of pre-train it,
train it, retrain it, and so on. I won't
go into the details. This is a
preliminary work, by the way. So,
hopefully we will get better and better.
But, the training process seems to be
like a mess.
We use our for ground truth data, we use
plate simulation, which is very
time-consuming. The reason, of course,
it's time-consuming is we have like a
lot of nodes, right?
Uh it's a two-dimensional I have to take
I have to create a mesh in 2D.
And then in the ribbon model, instead of
taking a mesh in 2D, I'm just using a
center line.
Now, for narrow ribbons,
all of them will agree, right? My
neural network or node-based method, my
DR, and my ground truth, all of them
will agree.
And I have my midpoint height as a
function of the displacement that I'm
applying. So, all of them can agree.
And then if the ribbon gets wider,
uh
the plate and ribbon the node-based
model, they kind of they agree better
than DR model. So, here I have my plate
model,
my neural node neural ODE-based model,
and uh experiments, they're here. And my
DR simulation that is farther off. Of
course, the node simulation is not there
yet. There's still some some
There are still some deviations, but we
hope to get better and better at it.
In summary,
uh the neural networks can be used to
represent the elastic energy of a like a
wider ribbon
using rod-like kinematics. Again,
because if you know that the underlying
governing PDE is just
mx'' is equal to the sum of forces. So,
this allows us to focus on just the
constant behavior.
And some of these problems have been um
have been baffling scientists for for
almost a century now.
All right.
To the last 10 minutes or so of my talk,
um and I want to talk about inverse
design. Okay, so so so far what we have
been saying is like I can simulate these
things, I can go forward. I take a
configuration, I see how it behaves, how
it deforms under
a bunch of external forces and so on.
But the real value of these simulations
is when I can use them for you know, for
inverse design. Like how the robot
should move or how I should
uh design this manufacturing process and
so on.
So, what here I'll be doing is I'll be
going over and
and something that's very exciting to us
is how to develop a planar fabrication
process so that I can get
three-dimensional shape of target
features.
For example, let's say I want to get a
hemispherical curve hemispherical uh
hemispherical cap
starting from a planar shape. Or I can
imagine that I want to
uh fabricate the face of a human to
create masks or I want to fabricate a
wig
um and so on. The reason we care about
this is because um I can use a lot of
existing three- uh like 3D printing
tools like PCB printers and so on. So, I
can take my planar shape, print a bunch
of stuff on it, and then I can deploy
that in 3D.
So, we have thought about using them for
health monitoring, so on. This is a fake
mouse, not real.
And we can also, of course,
reduce the volume for transportation.
When When you take a three-dimensional
shape and you stretch it everywhere,
you'll see wrinkles and folds and so on.
But,
in this method, I take a planar shape, I
develop that into a three-dimensional
shape, and then if I stretch everywhere,
it will actually take a planar shape.
So, I can stack one on top of another,
send it up to space, for example, let's
say, and then I can deploy it as needed.
Now, the concept that we'll be using two
fundamental concept
behind it. The first concept is the idea
of strain mismatch, okay?
So, in 1D, this concept goes back to
John Harrison, who was a clockmaker in
England. If I have a bimetallic strip,
once one metal has higher thermal
coefficient than the other and I heat it
up, it will take a curved shape that is
used in as a circuit breaker and so on.
In 2D,
let's say I take
two layers of plates, top layer and
bottom layer, I stretch the bottom
layer, and I glue the two two together,
I will create a so-called soft
composite.
The shape of that composite, if I
release it,
we naively thought that it is going to
be
hemispherical, because it's symmetric,
there's radial symmetry in the
fabrication, so you know, if if I
make a composite like this, of course,
it should take
I we thought that it will take a
hemispherical shape, but in reality,
what happens is it takes like a crumpled
shape. It has wrinkles. We call it a
pre-buckled shape.
Very quickly, we have fabrication We
have come with a like a pretty good
experimental device for this
to make this thing. So, we take a
piston, and we fix bottom layer on top
of it. Then I screw up the piston to
stretch the bottom layer. This way, I
can control the amount of pre-stretch in
my bottom layer.
I put my unstretched top layer on top of
it, and then I cut this part, I cut the
composite and it takes a free buckling
shape. And of course we have experiments
too. We have done actual experiments.
These are some photographs and CAD
models from our experiments.
Now,
um to understand a little bit more why
this happens,
we can just use pure physics.
So, we depending on how much pre-stretch
I put in, I can get
zero wrinkles, two wrinkles, three
wrinkles, or four wrinkles. And why that
happens?
So, let's say plot my strain energy as a
function of pre-stretch and I assume
that my shape is going to be like a
hemisphere or hemispherical cap, then I
will have a curve like this. This is
qualitative curve by the way. I will
show you like a real plots later.
But if I assume that it will take a
equals to two shape, I will have a curve
like this, okay? So, between
after a critical value of pre-stretch,
it is energetically favorable for the
for the composite to take a equals to
two.
Now, the real plots, the real energy
landscape will look like this and I'm
not going into the details of this. The
point to show is that
two energy curves can be very parallel
to one another
and they're not just two, but a lot of
different possible mode shapes.
All right.
So, however, even though we can
understand the forward process, our
inverse problem is still
not solved, right?
For that, what we do is we introduce
another concept of kirigami.
Right?
So, now what I'm going to do instead of
taking the top layer, I'm going to cut
the top layer along specific directions.
And the kirigami pattern, depending on
the kirigami pattern, we can get we can
we have control over the
three-dimensional shape, right?
And so, we have experiments and
simulations. So, I'm using this lotus
shaped pattern that we came up with
heuristically and then did some
experiments with it.
Depending on pre-stretch, you can see
that initially
at 15 or 10 5% pre-stretch, it is like a
hemispherical cap, then it takes k
equals to two or taco shape, and then if
I get 25 to 30% pre-stretch, it again
goes back to hemisphere and
hemispherical shape. This is really
interesting, right?
Now, if I'm dealing with hemispherical
shape,
then I can
uh
I can use some theoretical analysis and
do use answers and so on to to kind of
come up with this method.
But,
what if I want some other shape? I want
What if I want like a flower or peanut
shape? Then how do you go about it? So,
this is where we'll be using uh machine
learning and specifically variational
autoencoder.
Kind of the idea is this, that we know
from computer vision that um
the
a
a family of images actually lie in a
much smaller dimensional manifold,
right?
So, I can take a bunch a lot of kirigami
patterns, train an encoder network,
reduce this let's say 64 by 64 by or 128
by 128 pixels to
five to 10 latent features.
And then, of course, I can feed it
through the decoder network, and
hopefully we will get the training
uh we'll get the original kirigami
pattern.
So, instead of optimizing for these
images, we optimize in the latent space,
and we have to add two physical
parameters to account for kind of the
physics and mechanics. One is the
pre-stretch lambda as well as the size
R, the size of the of the structure. And
then we feed it through active learning
framework. Um and it turns out that
active learning works better than some
other existing uh some other frameworks
that I don't know exactly why, but um
something that could be studied later.
Whatever framework you use for
simulation for optimization doesn't
matter.
Um the point is I'm I'm using latent
features to
to optimize for.
So, let's go over the training process
very quick. So, let's say I want to
focus on structure that have
reflectional symmetry, right? So, I'll
be taking the first quadrant and I will
be dividing the first quadrant into 13
regions. And I will be randomly picking
uh one to three or all 13 regions out of
those 13 regions. This will create a
training data set
and I will be using uh this training
data, I believe about 70,000 training
images to train my auto variational
autoencoder.
And we also account for reflectional and
various types of symmetries. Uh so, in
the training data, whenever there is a
training data, we take the symmetric
versions of that as well.
Now, how many latent features do I need?
It turns out after I run the
optimization and so on and do some
experiments,
so, if I plot the structural similarity
index measure, I'm going to ex- I will
go over what I mean by this uh later,
as a function of latent features, looks
like after about six latent features, uh
there's not a lot of change in uh
there's not a lot of change in in uh in
quality.
The structural similarity index measure,
it represents uh
essentially, we are looking at the
height at all the nodes
uh and comparing the comparing and
comparing two structures using those
heights, and that helps us get a
similarity measure. One means perfect,
zero means the worst.
So, now I only have six numbers plus
couple more to optimize for.
Uh let's go over some examples.
So, let's say my target shape is like
this.
So, I get my solution kirigami pattern
using my latent features
and then couple of
physical parameters. The experiments
simulations and experiments
and plotting structural similarity index
measure as a function of uh
as a function of the number of
iterations. It looks like after about 61
iterations, we get about 91% accuracy,
which is kind of good enough. But we
could have you know tried more and more,
but uh that is kind of good enough for
us.
Also, multiple solutions. We can get
multiple solutions. Um
you know, for the same target shape,
which is
which is like it is known that we should
get multiple solution that there are
multiple solutions, but it is nice to
see that we can actually get multiple
solutions from the same framework.
Then let's talk about our uh another
example where we wanted to start a
flower shape get a flower shape. I have
my solution 92% accuracy uh simulations
and experiments and it takes about you
know, about actually it takes just about
40 to 50 iterations or so. Which is
which I think is is pretty impressive uh
given uh and Dr.
Ma and Rumen Muqer did this work and
they I think they did a pretty good job
in cutting down the competition time. Of
course, we can do a lot more examples.
Now,
very quickly in the last 3 minutes or
so,
a really cool part of this is we can
actually make it bistable, right?
So,
instead of the structure being soft and
three-dimensional, I can make it
bistable for that it so that it can be
used to grip or grasps grasp something.
The concept is similar.
The only difference is instead of one
kirigami layer and one substrate layer,
I will have one kirigami layer, a
substrate layer, and then a bottom
kirigami layer, right?
And
we did some indentation experiments to
actually show that it is it is bistable.
So, I'm plotting force as a function of
displacement and of course it goes
through a peak and then goes through a
minimum.
Now, interestingly, we can actually use
our same solution that I introduced to
do its inverse design. Okay. So, if I
want to get with a hemispherical cap
shape or a peanut shape,
I can do it using
my bilayer setup, which is what I
discussed monostable bilayer setup which
I discussed like a couple of minutes
ago.
If I apply the same solution to the
tri-layer case, it doesn't work. Right?
So, it does not work. However, if I just
tune two parameters, I can actually use
the same kirigami pattern to get the
tri-layer shape. This, I believe, can be
explained some through some simple
energy balance and so on, uh which we
don't do in our studies, but uh it is
good to know that we can actually use,
you know, like a variational autoencoder
to reduce the order of the model and
then come up with bistable structures of
target shapes and use them for things
like uh soft robotic gripper. So, we can
we actuate them uh in this case using uh
shape memory alloy, and here the there's
no
actuation in here. Just under its own
weight, it will it will get actuated.
So, with that, I'd like to summarize by
saying that we can use discrete
differential geometry-based simulations
using pure physics for simulation of
robots in contact, and then we combine
that with machine learning to reduce the
order of the model, and then we use the
variational autoencoder for model
reduction to come up with uh some
inverse design methods. I'd like to
thank my funding agencies, National
Science Foundation and USDA and
Department of Energy, as well as Amazon
for supporting this work. And if there's
any time, I'd like to uh take any
questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you so much for the
wonderful talk, Harit. Uh that was very
interesting talk. Uh yeah, let's have a
Q&A session. Um
Is there any question from audience? You
can unmute yourself and ask.
I can start with one. If you go to
Caligami, you know, the the auto encoder
the training case, I see that you just
look at the first quadrant and divide
into 13.
Yes.
And you are are you saying you're
training auto encoder
like 13 different auto encoder here or
Uh no. Um
I didn't
Yeah.
follow.
It means like yes, so we have to
basically we have to take arbitrary
kirigami patterns to train the auto
encoder, right?
Yeah.
So this is a way of systematizing the
arbitrary data generation part.
So in So we train one auto encoder, but
we
train we generate training data by
taking let's say my in first training
data, I I will have this region one,
two, and three and everything else will
be off, right? So then I will have a
training I will have an image that will
have just
one, two, and
Just uh yeah, one, two, and three and
then I will have let's say one, two, and
three and then let's say I want to take
one, five, and nine, right?
Right.
So by training it this way
uh even though we
So by training it this way we can
generate training data that
allows the auto encoder to generalize.
So for example, when I get my solutions,
right? Uh
But like for example here, they're not I
cannot generate my this solution using
uh my training data generation method.
Um So in in summary, it was it's just a
way of systematizing the training data
generation.
I see I see. So that's your parameter
space like some sort of combinatorial.
Yeah, yes, yeah.
parameter space, yeah.
Okay, got it. Thank you. All right, is
there any question from audience?
Uh one more question from you. Well,
then, um
those
you got that from experimental
data, right? I mean, those
to train the autoencoder
I guess you could
do that experimentally very easily.
And get the and put that in the
autoencoder training.
What did you use as the seed?
Yeah, we used we used uh we didn't I
wouldn't even call it simulation. It's
just like
MATLAB script to generate random images.
And we
trained the autoencoder using randomly
generated synthetic synthetic images.
And then it is um then we
run the whole optimization then we do
the training thing and then we run the
whole optimization scheme to find out
what are the best latent parameters.
Then we can using those latent
parameters you can recreate this image
and then implement that in experiments.
And then what we see is the experiments
and simulations will agree.
I see.
Uh can you share a you know
I think you did mention that, but um can
you elaborate um what this kind of
you know, the designs, you know, um
can be applied to, you know, the
potential applications of of this?
Yeah. So, uh there are a couple I mean,
there is this monostable things, right?
I can get like three-dimensional shapes.
So, now let's say um I want to have So,
patient-specific
uh health care monitoring patch, for
example, right?
Uh everybody's head, everybody's
kneecap, everybody's you know, like
arms, they're different. So, I can let's
say 3D scan part of a human body and
come up with
a shape that will conform to that part
of the body. But because the fabrication
process happens in three in just planar,
it's a two-dimensional
during the fabrication process on top of
the substrate layer, for example, I can
print circuits to to to detect, let's
say, when a patient falls. Or I can and
I can write circuits to monitor glucose
or whatever.
That's one. But I think
for us, given that we have a we try to
we have some work in robotics, uh the
bistability is pretty
neat. So, I can um
So, bistability means that I can go from
one shape to the other and I don't need
to keep applying power to it. I only
need to apply power to transition from
one shape to the other. So, that can be
used for uh multimodal
locomotion. And we do have a paper with
uh Carmel Majidi and Lining Yao's group
that uses bistability to for
reconfigurable amphibious um robots. And
so, if it if it can reconfigure itself,
then it can be like a quadruped that is
walking on the that is walking on sand
for some time and then it can start
swimming. But now it's legs could be
converted to be to be some type of
propelling mechanism.
Mhm.
I see.
Yeah, I mean, it's
probably there are more applications of
this um which we cannot think of for
now. But yeah, that's very interesting
and um you know, exciting stuff.
Absolutely.
Is there any
other question from audience?
Um
if not, let's let's thank our deep
speaker uh today uh for the wonderful
talk um
from Khalid. Um thank you so much,
Khalid.
Thank you so much. Thank you for hosting
me.